et aujourd'hui ça a remanimé ça a
remanimé et regardez la réaction
regardez la réaction de cette Mara non
mais franchement non mais l'autre
anidalgoal mais quelle lourdeur je
souhaite bon courage aux acteurs du
monde de la culture cont tenu des
épreuves qui vont traverser mais tu as
souhaité bon courage au parisiens avec
les
épreuves non mais franchement nonidalgo
non mais Anne hiidalgo qui non mais elle
elle elle s rigoler c'est y a un film
comme ça AC Gard par et et Pierre
Richard s'appelle les fugitifs et Gérard
pardu il est en Caval et il y a un gars
qui dit quand on est en Caval on se fait
tout petit petit petit pe petit 175 au
analgo c'est comme si elle était en
Caval mais elleelle encore là elle
tranquille elle se permet de tweeter
elle se permet d'envoyer des bailes non
mais sans rigoler la meuf elle était à
Tahiti pendant 2 mois pour faire du surf
non mais mais c'est pas possible non
mais c'est c'est fou hein elle c'est le
rock fort qui qui qui se moque du
camemberber non mais je vous jure
j'adore arachida latim en plus j'aurais
préféré qu'elle soit mère de Paris hein
parce que je peux te dire qu' aurais
moins de rat et il y aurait mieux moins
de Gill
Verdez parce que Gilles Verdez je te
regarde et je sais ce que tu vas dire et
déjà déjà de toute façon frère je
t'explique déjà ça fait 3 jours que tu
es là déjà frère déjà déjà je t'explique
tes yeux déjà on les voit plus déjà tu
as des yeux on reg on dirait des dessous
de porte euh je te dis tellement tu es
éclaté éclaté gentil avec j'ai vu ta
tête quand j'ai parlé d' duré un jour
bah oui non de de bah aujourd'hui j'ai
pas dit que j'allais pas êre gentil mais
là là annidalgo non mais non mais
annidalgo annidalgo mais elle a fait 1
75 mais c'est quoi le bilan de
annalgo j'ai ri moi lui parle pas
lui péton Paris comme jamais Paris est
sale comme jamais Paris est endetté
comme jamais donc
excuse-moi tu vois pas que Paris a le BL
attends tu as vu la non mais c'est vrai
non mais arrête ne défends pas
l'indéfendable ne défends pas
l'indéfendable ça fait des semaines et
des années que tu défends
l'indéfendable pas parl il a pas besoin
de parler parce que je le vois
alors je te demande juste une question
est-ce que tu as failli défendre an
nidalgo oui voilà c'est mec je le
connais mais lui mais lui tu sais quoi
mais lui mais lui heureusement que je
fais pas des déis avec lui ça part en
cacahuète ah ce serait bien d'ailleurs
je vous invite il y a les assiettes qui
volent ah mais toi je te jure c'est
comme un jour moi un jour moi j'ai fait
un dîner avec Benjamin castalni j'étais
avec mon ami Jean Rachid je vous jure
que c'est vrai et Benjamin castalni il s
rappelle moi il il avait un petit peu
but ah oui et il commençait à me
demander une augmentation mais je vous
jure que l'histoire est vraie l'histoire
est vraie il commenc à me demander une
orientation une augmentation au début je
rigole 10 minutes je rigole encore 20
minutes et là il y a jeanachide il voit
que ça commence à à
Brill donc là il lui dit écoute arrêteou
stop parce que ça va se terminer on va
devoir le l'enterrer dans le jardin
bjachid il je me voyais déjà avec lappel
le truc ça part ça ça en cacahuète et il
l'a pris et il a sorti de la mais mais
ah ou carrément ililtré et qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait il a exfiltré de la maison
et Benjamin Castaldi il l' laissé après
et lui il est parti il est remonté et
Benjamin castal a perdu le chemin de la
maison mais non on l'a jamais plus
revu l'histoire pouz lui
demander après il arrêtait pas de nous
appeler personne lui répondit perdu dans
la rue il était perdu parce que c'était
très compliqué pour revenir chez moi tu
le sais et donc je peux te dire castal
terminé perdu et voilà donc nous regarde
c'est je l'aime maintenant et je lui
donnerai toutes les augmentations qu'il
veut parce qu'il travaille plus avec moi
mais il est content je l'ai au téléphone
sa pièce est capté pour
France exctement mais je l' également je
l'ai tous les jours pratiquement
Benjamin je l'adore carement ouais
j'aime plus les chroniqueurs qui partent
que ceux qui restent c'est fou c'est fou
non mais je dire c'est fou c'est fou
c'est fou c'est fou c'est fou vous
connaissez C Golen Royal oui non vous
qu'est es con toi non mais sans rigoler
elle était toute contente de dire oui je
connaissais goen Royal con bien sûr je
la connais mais vous la connaissiez
avant qu'elle soit dans l'émission oui
bien sûr vous l'aimiez bien j'adore
c'est vrai oui vous avez dit assez de
connerie hier aujourdhui je vais
calmer d'ailleurs j'aimerais dire
quelque chose non non mais ne dis plus
rien c'est bon qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire non je voudrais m'excuser parce que
mes propos étaient un peu cru d'accord
et moi ce que je voulais juste dire
c'est que peu importe l'orientation
sexuelle l'important c'est personne soit
un bon ministreê compétent exactement
déjà il démarre bien avec le nomination
déjà qui nous a foutu dehors Rama Rima
Abdou malac là non mais c'est non mais
elle c'est pas possible je sais pas ce
qu'elle va maintenant de ses
journé ça fait quoi une min comme ça qui
ple rien qui fait rien elleessa
deer il va vouloir d' avec toutes les
conneries Olivier qui est plus portepole
Priska qui
vient être
ministre il a jou la semaine dernière
juste après moi mais on s'est croiséou
vouses parlé un peu on s'est croisé je
l'ai pas vu il y a des gens qui m'ont
ditivier est venu jouer juste après toi
je le ai dit alors ils m'ont dit c'est
pas joli joli il on demandé il demandé
s'il voulait prendre des cours avec moi
il a dit écoute avec grand plaisir bon
il y a royal qui nous attend très
heureux par c'est la prière fois que
jeav 2024 c'est une des premières à
m'avoir dit bonne année ou une des
premièresandidate à l'élection
présidentielle m'a écrit à moioun ok
vous j'attends toujours personne'
personne qui m'a dit qui m'a dit bonne
année
tous c'est
vrai non vous c'est vrai vous c'est vrai
vous c'est vrai vous c'est vrai vous
c'est vrai non toi non non toi tu es une
merde merde je crois que vous aimiez pas
ça me
oui mais vous étiez peut-être ensemble
non non répondu à vos vœux parce que
vous êtes le plus jeune donc c'est le
plus jeune qui souhaite donc toi tu
grande forcment si tuattends qu'on soit
plus jeune que toi tu trouves un mec
plus vieux que toi pour te souhaiter fa
que tu sois plus jeune qu'un autre gars
pour lui souhaiter ah ouais d'accord
donc tu as pas dû souiter beaucoup de
monde et Gil Verdez le premier comme
d'habitude mon chéri d'amouri que je
défendrai toujours oh là là oui j'ai une
très bonne nouvelle selon une étude les
Français sont en train de retrouver le
moral puisque à part Gill Verdez malgré
le froid et l'inflation les Français ont
le moral qui grimpe est-ce que vous avez
le moral ici autour de la tableou oui
quoi qui oui vous oui oui ouii bien sûr
oui oui oui non oui pas pas ouf là-bas
les deux là toi toi non moi je gement
faitv toi pas trop hein toi non plus
hein mais pas trop vous moi si ça va
très bien pas ouf ah ouais j'ai
l'impression non ah non ça va très bien
vraiment et vous à moi pas ouf top bogil
on
sait tuas le moral dans les chaussettes
hein pas ouf du tout ah oui mais tu tu
t'as pas dormi depuis quelle année non
c'est une petite irritation à l'œil
droit que vous confondez avec une
absence de sommeil j'ai un j'ai pris un
moustique un truc volant dans
l'œil janvier en hiver il a pris seld
gar il a pris un moustique en hiver dans
l'œil
excuse-moi ça t'alerte pas ça vous
alerte pas vous c'est le seul qui prend
un moustique dans l'œil en ça vous
alerte pas il y a un moustique non mais
il y a un Mousti qui va dans l'œil de
Gill Verdez un organe vivant boou ah
ouais un organe vivant bah écoute ça te
changera de ce que tu as dans le C allez
regardez les Français ont le moral
regarde c'est une info qui nous donne
pas mal d'espoir les Français sont en
train de retrouver le moral car malgré
une actualité pesante et l'inflation qui
met à mal de nombreux Français
maintenant on se prive de de pas mal de
choses le moral des français serait donc
bel et bien en hausse selon une enquête
de Linc ils sont même 24 % a déclaré
être confiant concernant l'avenir
économique du
[Musique]
pays qu'est-ce qui vous donne le moral
vous qu'est-ce qui vous donne le moral
si vous dit voilà ça va bien vous ah ben
moi venir ici retrouver
les même pas payer ça vous donn le moral
quand même alors ça une petite baisse de
moralme qu'est-ce vous donne le moral
vous janvier c'est jamais très bon donne
le moral dans la vie moi là de
travailler de prendre de l'OSE quoi
d'accordâ le ces proche le pigeon qui
parleil moi venir ici ça me sauve vrai
autrement j'ai le moral dans les
chaussettes ouis quand tu viens pas pas
bien quoi manger ou danser ah ouais ah
j'adore manger tu as dit manger ou
danser moi danser ça me donne le morale
pas vous venir ici tu t'en fous
alors manger ou danser lui on dirait que
je suis honnête moi ils disent venir ici
vous c'est quoi c'est vrai avec avec
Guillaume on disait que depuis janvier
avait une ambiance incroyable sur le
plateau donc c'est vrai que venir ici
c'est plutôt chouette jours ouais mais
c'est
vrai qui met de bonne humeur c'est jouer
au tennis jouer au poker et et faire des
bouffes avec des enfin des bons dinîner
avec des potes j'ai jamais fait un
dinîner avec vous donc apparemment oui
mais vous aimez pas vous acceptez pas
vous dites que vous refusez toutes les
invitations à dîner boulot trop bouot
vous détestez les dîners en couple
machinite tout j les D le pire ser de
vous inviter et finalement vous plantiez
ouais bah faitesle on verra bien bah
ouais mais bon quand merci ok je vais
tenter vous c'est quoi désolé le seul
romantique mais moi le sourire de ma
chérie quand j'entre le soir à la maison
oui les garsou dans
vieou dans Vie les gar et vous moi
j'adore rencontrer mes abonnés dans la
rue vous vous êtes vraiment elle a juré
sur ses réseaux sociaux sur la tête de
mes réseaux sociaux ça ve c'est plus
important super important si demain
alors je vous dis un truc si demain ou
vous perdez tous vos abonnés ou
malheureusement un des chroniqueurs
passe l'arme à gauche choisissez quoi
cl vous comprenez ce que je ouais ou
voilà pour perdez tous vos abonnés
c'esté dire que le chroniqueur est mort
oui ah oui oui ma gauche est décédé tout
le monde meurt un jour hein voilà
d'accord voilà merci on l' compris merci
sauver ses abonnés Daniel allez